data protection is of paramount
importance in today's world the vast
amount of data flow between corporations
and consumer needs to be secured
considering that they are entrusted with
a lot of belief
the company can spend millions of
dollars on the most secure servers but
it takes a single hacker to ruin all the
goodwill between the organizations
to prevent these malicious attacks many
automated security systems have been
developed but none of them have been as
used as ids platforms which are also
known as intrusion detection systems
welcome to this introductory lesson on
intrusion detection systems so let's go
through the topics that we are going to
cover today
we started the basic definition of ideas
from a layman's perspective
the moving on we cover the multiple
types of intruders that seek to access
confidential information without any
authorization
next we cover the basic ways to detect
intrusion signatures from the
perspective of a network administrator
we then take a look at the different
types of ideas systems that can be used
in corporate environments today
a small explanation of the two types of
protection is then followed by an
introduction to some of the most
well-known ideas tools on the market
so let's get started with what is an ids
an intrusion detection system is an app
or device that monitors inbound and
outward network traffic continuously
analyzing for activity changes and
patterns and alerts an administrator
when it detects unusual behavior
an administrator then reviews alarms and
take action to remove the threat
for example an ids might inspect the
data carried by network traffic to see
if it contains known malware or other
malicious content
if it detects this type of threat it
sends an alert to your security team so
they can investigate and remediate it
once your team receives the alert they
must act quickly to prevent an attack
from taking over the system
to ensure that the ids doesn't slow down
network performance the solutions often
use a switched port analyzer or a text
access port to analyze a copy of the
inline data traffic so that they do not
meddle with the actual traffic
however they do not block threat once
they enter the network as intrusion
prevention systems do
regardless of whether you set up a
physical device or an ids program the
system can recognize attack patterns
with network packets monitor user
behavior identify abnormal network
activity or ensure user and system
activity do not go against security
policies
the main goal of an ideas is to detect
the anomalies before the hackers
complete the objective once the system
detects a threat the it team is informed
and the information is passed on
given the requirement for understanding
context an enterprise has to be ready to
make any ideas fit its own unique needs
expert advice
what this means is that an ids cannot be
a one-size-fits-all configuration to
operate accurately and effectively
and this requires a savvy ideas analyst
to tailor the ideas for the interests
and needs of a given site
a knowledgeable trained system analyst
ask cash
the trick with ideas is that you have to
know what the attack is to be able to
identify it
the ids has always had the patient zero
problem
you have to have found someone who got
sick and died before you can identify it
it can usually go for two types of
protection
active protection and passive
in a passive system the ids detects a
potential security breach logs the
information and signals an alert
in a reactive system or an active system
the ids responds to the suspicious
activity by logging off a user or by
reprogramming the firewall to block
network traffic from the suspected
malicious source
so now that we understand what an ids is
let us go through the different types of
intruders ids platforms must be aware of
to understand this type of intruders let
us go through a scenario
we have the servers which are protected
by the ids platforms in place
so let's say a hacker tries to breach
the system from outside the organization
this can be done using multiple attacks
like ddos attacks injection attacks etc
the category of individuals that are not
authorized to use the system but still
exploit users privacy and confidential
information using different techniques
are known as masqueraders
a masquerader is an intruder that is an
outsider who does not have direct access
to the system and aims to attack
unethically by stealing data or
information
however there is another intruder who is
theoretically harder to detect and
approve than a masquerader
these are the people within the
organization who want to weaken the
security defenses be it for corporate
espionage or to aid other masqueraders
the category of individuals that are
authorized to use a system but misuse
the granted access and privilege
these are individuals that take undue
advantage of the permissions and give
access to them and this category of
intruders are known as miss visa
misfeasions are people that are insiders
and have direct access to the system
which they aim to attack unethically by
stealing data or information
let us now go through some of the ways
the ideas platforms can detect intrusion
before registering
intrusion detection systems primarily
use two key methods one is signature
page intrusion and anomaly based
intrusion
signature based intuition detection is
designed to detect possible threats by
comparing the given network traffic and
log data to existing attack patterns
these patterns are called sequences and
could include byte sequence which is
also known as malicious instruction
sequences
signature based detection enables you to
accurately detect and identify possible
known attacks
anomaly based intrusion detection is the
opposite
it's designed to pinpoint unknown
attacks such as new malware and adapt to
them on the fly using machine learning
machine learning techniques enable an
intrusion detection system to create
baselines of trustworthy activity which
is known as a trust model then compare
new behaviors to verify trust models
false alarms can occur when using an
anomaly based idea since previously
unknown yet legitimate network traffic
could be falsely identified as malicious
activity now if you combine both of
those you have the hybrid intuition
detection
they use signature based and anomaly
based intuition detection to increase
the scope of your ideas
this enables you to identify as many
threats as possible a comprehensive
intrusion detection system can
understand the evision techniques
cybercriminals use to trick an ideas to
thinking there isn't an attack taking
place
these techniques could include
fragmentation low bandwidth attack
pattern change division and many more
we can now take a look at the type of
protection offered by ids platforms
there are a couple of ways that can be
set up so let's go through each method
the first is a network based ids
the sensors are deployed at strategic
points within the network such as within
the dmz or at the network's perimeter
the sensor can monitor individual
packets of inbound and outbound traffic
to and from all devices on the network
it analyzes them for malicious activity
and depending on the network
architecture and amount of traffic
involved multiple instances of
network-based ideas may be necessary
the second category is host based
intrusion detection systems or
hids an agent runs on all servers
endpoints and devices in the network
that have access to both the internet
and the internal network
intuitions identified by analyzing
operating specific activities like the
modification of the file system registry
or access control lists
and by monitoring system application
logs as well
they augment network-based idea systems
by detecting anomalous traffic which
originate within the organization or
from the host that is being monitored
for example a host infected with malware
that has attempted to spread it to other
internal hosts is an issue that a
network-based ideas could potentially
fail to detect
the third variant is a cloud-based
intrusion detection system
because of the internet facing nature of
the cloud on-premises id solutions are
not necessarily optimized for monitoring
for example network-based sensors need
to be deployed within the cloud at an
environment's network perimeter and yet
a cloud service provider may or may not
have a way to facilitate this
cloud-based servers use purpose-built
cloud sensors that use cloud service
provider application programming
interface or cloud service provider apis
to get as much visibility as possible
into your cloud environment
now that we understand the different
types of ids deployment tactics let us
go through some tools that excel in this
field offering top of the line
implementations and a corporate and
consumer environment
the first tool being covered is the
solarwinds security event manager
the solarwinds security event manager is
designed to integrate real-time log data
from across your infrastructure enabling
it to act both as a network-based idea
system and a host-based idea system
the solution can let you discover all
kinds of malicious attacks and help you
protect your network from harm
it is also designed to enact both
signature based and anomaly-based
intuition detection by comparing
sequences of network traffic against a
set of customizable rules
next we have the mcafee livesafe
mcv livesafe is an intrusion detection
system designed to bring a real-time
threat awareness to your physical and
virtual networks
it uses signature-based intuition
prevention and anomaly-based intrusion
detection along with emulation
techniques to spot and identify
malicious activity
mcafee is also built to correlate threat
activity with application usage which
can further prevent network issues
stemming from cyber attacks
next we have bloomera
bloomera is a security information and
event management platform built to enact
threat detection and responses across
your cloud and on-premises environments
it is designed to continuously monitor
your i.t infrastructure for suspicious
activity and misconfigurations both of
which could result in data leaks and
compliance breaches
it enables you to respond to an attack
in progress and stop malicious actors in
their tracks
hope you learned something new today
please let us know if you find any
issues regarding ideas in the comment
section below subscribe to our channel
for more videos like this and thank you
for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn nerd up and get certified
click here